across nevada continuing to wait for
unemployment benefits some of those
people
are veterans joe moeller spoke to one
man who is desperate for a response from
dieter
he is live tonight with more joe
brian while we were at the deter office
here in las vegas a man had pulled up
and was walking around and
was looking for anybody to get some
answers there he is a veteran he did
serve his country and now
he hopes his government can help him and
then when i get to the submit pla
the final page to submit it on in red
letters it says
it needs to be reviewed by detr jason
zabak served in the navy from 1998
through 2012.
serve my country so i mean you know i
mean i'm just trying to get
keep on applying for a while until i get
a job and go back to work
since the pandemic began people across
the state have been trying to file for
unemployment benefits
thousands have waited months without any
money zaybach who worked at a concrete
cutting company
has been waiting since last month i sent
a letter to these guys
i try to call them but they're can't
talk anybody and
this goes a voicemail with nowhere else
to turn he came to the deter office in
las vegas one night to see if any
employee can help with its claim every
day i'm writing letters to the
unemployment office to the governor's
office i've
emailed the mayor the stories from
people waiting for money continue to
flood into 8 news now
in the past deters said they are working
to address the backlog of claims but the
stories are not stopping
some have waited six to eight months you
want me to like be holding a sign out
there by the guys on the freeway
looking for money i'll be like a veteran
say hey
combat veteran needs money zabak says
meantime he is trying to get a job
i just feel like i'm just like kind of
betrayed
you know and we have reached out to
dieter regarding the backlog and the
appeals process that many out there are
waiting for we have yet to hear back as
soon as we do
we'll be sure to pass it on to you
reporting live joe mohler 8 news now